[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7,8
choisi hier avec vous retrouver pour 13
minutes et est sorti tout de suite le
sommaire de ce jeudi 24 janvier le 24
janvier c'est d'ailleurs la journée
mondiale du sport féminin création du
conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel pour
sensibiliser sur la faible médiatisation
des sportives nous recevrons des membres
de la section féminine du club de
football de trappes pour en parler
il a été fondé en janvier 1989 fête
cette année ses 30 ans pour l'occasion
le théâtre alexandre dumas de saint
chaptes saint germain on les propose
trois jours festifs du 25 au 27 janvier
expositions spectacles et même visite
des coulisses le programme est riche
pour cette nouvelle dizaine puis nous
partirons à la découverte de l'univers
du photographe sebastiao salgado
l'artiste ali son intérêt pour
l'humanisme à son talent pour la photo
dans une exposition consacrée aux droits
de l'homme
[Musique]
en 2014 le conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel constaté la faible
médiatisation du sport féminin et décidé
de créer la journée internationale du
sport féminin pour sensibiliser au sujet
cette journée c'est aujourd'hui le 24
janvier et pour l'occasion nous
recevrons rodrigues lisible responsable
de la section féminine de l'étoile
sportive de trappes et sonia fernandez
mélina fernandez j'ai gardé le nom de ta
copine jours aux u17
bonjour tous les deux bon sans bride
alors le strap dispose de six équipes
féminines et obtenu le label or de la
fédération française de football
c'est une section à part entière du club
tout à faire donc c'est un axe de
développement majeur pour nos clubs
d'europe donc en 2013 2 présente
harbaoui à l'époque avait mille souhait
de lancer notre section féminine donc
chose qui a pu se réaliser grâce à
l'attribution d'un terrain synthétique
au stade du riz hybride donc depuis bad
essor du foot féminin à la trappe n'en
démord pas donc si on il ya cinq ans
elle était douzaine aujourd'hui c'était
en été sur un petit embryon est
aujourd'hui on peut se gargariser
d'avoir matin une centaine de filles
âgés de 6 à 23 ans club a bien grossi
donc si je reçois un club de football
aujourd'hui c'est pas par hasard cette
année la france accueille la coupe du
monde féminine
elle aura lieu du 7 juin au 7 juillet
pour la première fois on pourra même
voir certaines rencontres sur tf1 alors
c'est un événement vous attendez mélina
il est prévu de le voir et des choses
qui vont s'organiser entre copines
oui on l'a sûrement le regarde entre
copines se retrouver pour regarder le
braque et le fait que ce soit médiatisé
de façon plus importante que d'habitude
on pense quoi
ils voient dans la question ça va être
médiatisé de façon plus importante que
d'habitude pratiquement comme les hommes
c'est quelque chose qui est qu'on peut
attendre quand on est une jeune sportive
comme ça oui tout à fait je pense que le
fait que ce soit à médiatiser sur des
heures de grande écoute va faire un bien
au niveau du sport féminin et du
football en général
d'ailleurs ça peut avoir une importance
pour le club à battre de façon dont on
attend une retombée équivalente à celle
des garçons
parce que tu es façon plus les filles
seront médiatisé plus à ce titre à des
vocations et pays et puis nous dans des
clubs
on devra répondre à cette à cette
demande automatiquement s'investir dans
cette région on compte faire pas mal de
choses en effet donc là au club on
essaie de voir si on peut pas essayer
d'attraper quelques quelques précieux
billets pour pouvoir participer à la
fête mais remise à sur la ville je pense
qu on n'organisera pas mal de choses
comme des petits tournois des opérations
découverte pour pouvoir favoriser
justement la participation à cette
grande fête du football féminin est en
partie oui
thérèse arrêté place des journées à
regarder encore pas encore tout à fait
alors c'est un événement qui peut avoir
son importance pour le club on l'a dit
même en potentiel d'accueil on attend il
ya des espoirs là dessus tout à fait
tout à fait tout à fait au niveau du
club tant que je disais tout à l'heure
c'est un axe de développement majeur
donc nous on essaye de proposer la même
pratique la même configuration que qu'on
peut bénéficier nos garçons non parce
qu'on parle de foot féminin mais c'est
un temps que je n'aime pas trop déployer
parce que c'est comme du football
pratiqué par des filles mais c'est comme
du football s'avère pratique ça même
sport donc automatiquement au club de
trappes on essaiera de disposer de
moyens conséquents pour pouvoir
accueillir nos filles dans les
meilleures conditions
merci au madrigal final d'être venus si
on n'aide pas notre plateau pour parler
cette thématique donc armé vous
peut-être mais là on peut venir te
supporter avec mon équipe oui le de
ferrer un match contre moi la jolie qui
se passera à 18 heures au stade chine
perd son sac
bon alors tous au stade gilbert son sac
de terreau et tout leur merci merci mode
mettre en valeur les sportifs c'était
l'idée de la ville de guyancourt pour la
journée nationale des droits des femmes
en 2018
pour cela elle avait fait une commande
un artiste local une exposition photos
sur les fautes sont les femmes et le
mouvement des aa n'a convoqué les
associations sportives de la ville pour
mettre en valeur ses pratiquants
escrimeuse danseuse gymnastes et non
professionnels
toutes ces sportifs guyancourt toise ont
été mises en valeur par le photographe
des ânes
l'exposition qui fêtera ses 1 en mars
prochain continue à vivre et s'offre une
tournée des gymnases j'ai découvert en
fait les rudiments de la photo sportive
donc ils appellent de s'adapter
mais en même temps voilà la photo
sportive le mouvement
énormément de grâce plus habitué aux
portraits posés l'artiste s'est essayé
au mouvement
à chaque pas chaque sport a été une
découverte un défi une technique d'
approche une technique d' approche non
je paye de sport favori pour un poids
pour faire ces photos ça et c'est
vraiment la découverte à chaque fois
s'adapter aux mouvements de sport
photographies mais aussi à la sportive
des ânes a rencontré une grande partie
des associations sportives de guyancourt
pour trouver ces volontaires beaucoup
plus gênant pour une femme de se faire
regarder en train de faire des
mouvements doivent se sentir
est ce que je fais mal ce que je fais
pas mal surtout qu'en fait c'étaient
principalement tout des nos vies il n'y
a aucune à tête aux professionnels sur
celle sur ces photos l'artiste est
revenu à ses premiers amours effet
essentiellement des portraits
aujourd'hui pour ne jamais frustré
d'inspiration soudaine son
appareil-photo l'accompagnent dans
toutes ses sorties
on reste dans le sport mais sous forme
digitale le tournoi de esport hairston
revient à versailles pour une deuxième
édition
l'hôtel de ville de ville accueille
trois compétitions ligne retransmise en
direct sur la webtv de armas team le
club de l'ispor français et sur les
réseaux sociaux de la ville nouveauté
cette année une table ronde sur le
phénomène
pas de souris d'ordinateur et de
claviers mais une raquette pour les
rencontre régionale de badminton
l'équipe honneur de montigny le
bretonneux affrontent les clubs de
boulogne et de frêne samedi 26 janvier
au gymnase pierre de coubertin
en janvier 1989 nez c'est à saint
germain en laye le théâtre alexandre
dumas un clin d'oeil à l'écrivain qui
avait lui même fondé un théâtre dans la
ville jalousé par les parisiens le thé à
des versions actuelles fête aujourd'hui
ses 30 ans pour ces trois dizaines trois
jours de festivités avec plusieurs
animations visites des coulisses
conférences expositions photos dans le
foyer totalement rénové l'équipe du
théâtre vous réserve plusieurs surprises
eut même un spectacle offert sophie
bauer la directrice déléguée du théâtre
donner des éléments dans le cetud
culture de mélanie poquet mardi dans 2
janvier les femmes d'une soeur rom
alors c'est une création qui a déjà une
grande renommée
ils ont fait énormément de tourner
l'année dernière c'est un spectacle a
rencontré un énorme succès public
donc on va dire on est parti sur une
valeur très sûre qui a déjà vraiment
rencontré un vraiment un très très bel
écho et c'est vrai c'est un spectacle
qui est pour le coup extrêmement
spectaculaire une technicité absolument
fabuleuse course et circassiens ils sont
au nombre de quatre dans un décor qui va
vraiment rendre hommage aux capacités
techniques du théâtre à son grand
plateau qui fait plus de 500 m² avec
notamment à l'immense machine mois dans
lequel les les circassiens vont pouvoir
effectuer des voltiges qui fait plus de
12 mètres de haut et donc voilà un très
bel une très belle proposition pour
trois représentations samedi à 14h et à
20h dimanche à 15h et c'est vrai que
c'est un spectacle tient à coeur parce
qu'il est aussi j'irai
trans-générationnel pour votre
rendez-vous dans les seules cinq
continents elle direction de cinéma les
yeux d'elsa à saint cyr l'école pour
parler d'une adaptation d'une pièce de
théâtre à succès patrick jane the big ce
musée propose t on au cinéma cette
semaine au cinéma les yeux d'elsa en
particulier c'est le film edmond alors
c'est un film de alexis michalik qui est
sorti récemment
petit retour en arrière la pièce de
théâtre 2010 cette aide mon grand grand
succès dans le théâtre privé 5 molière
enfin un véritable succès à paris et en
tournée en province le film donc vient
d'être réalisée est sorti en adaptation
à ce récit théâtral le film est réalisé
par l'auteur de la pièce et il s'amuse
vraiment dans ce film a travaillé du
cinéma évidemment le thé au théâtre on
est face à des acteurs sur une scène et
[Rires]
de la pièce cyrano de bergerac par
edmond rostand et bien là dans le film
il va nous faire faire ce qu'il peut pas
faire au théâtre c'est à dire qu'il va
nous faire entrer dans la pièce montée
sur scène être avec les acteurs être
avec les comédiens tournée avec je vous
conseille véritablement vivement c'est
une très très belle histoire d'amour
c'est une très belle histoire d'amitié
c'est une très belle histoire de
création et c'est une très belle
réflexion du cinéma sur le théâtre
j'espère que vous viendrez le voir
nombreux ici au cinéma les yeux d'elsa
cette semaine la semaine prochaine et
partout ailleurs en france c'est un film
qui vont vraiment le détour
[Musique]
le traditionnel salon warhammer du
centre alfred de vigny s'élargit à la
pop culture
un escape game harry potter un concours
cosplay et même des cours de cuisine
pique les alfred heer oseille c'est ce
week-end à voisins le bretonneux
vendredi 25 janvier c'est la sixième
nuit des conservatoires trois communes y
participent à saint quentin en yvelines
une première pour mort pas qu'il étend
jusqu au samedi et propose des styles
très différents en ajoutant même un peu
de théâtre
partons au musée de l'homme pour parler
des droits de l'homme
[Musique]
attaché aux valeurs humanistes le
photographe sebastiao salgado expose ses
déclarations une trentaine de
photographies pour illustrer les droits
de l'homme et leurs applications dans le
monde
reportage de miley schiro as de nos
confrères via grand paris tous les êtres
humains naissent libres et égaux en
dignité et en droits proclame le premier
article de la déclaration universelle
des droits de l'homme
dans les faits ce n'est pas toujours le
cas c'est ce que démontre le travail du
photographe humaniste sebastiao salgado
des mains des regards et des visages qui
traduisent l'horreur la pauvreté
l'incertitude dans un tirage de trente
clichés exclusivement en noir et blanc
[Musique]
alors on a sélectionné avec sebastiao
salgado neuf articles sur l'article
premier parti dit que tout humain tous
les humains naissent libres et égaux en
droits et en dignité mais bien aussi
parler du droit à l'éducation de la
lutte contre la torture le droit à la
liberté de circuler et caetera et en
fait donc les textes ou partie des
textes de ces articles sont inscrits sur
les murs et en dessous il ya des photos
de sebastiao salgado qui couvre
l'ensemble de la planète mais qui
justement à la limite montre
malheureusement le contraire
l'exposition déclaration constitue une
rétrospective du travail du photographe
pendant 40 ans sebastiao salgado a
parcouru le monde et a su immortaliser
le génocide rwandais
des scènes d'excision ou encore l'exil
des réfugiés mozambique ans on célèbre
depuis le 10 décembre j'ai 70 ans de la
déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme qui a été signé ici au palais de
chaillot au sortir de la seconde guerre
mondiale et donc le no musée de l'homme
nous avons décidé de faire une saison
pendant six mois une saison que nous
avons baptisé endroit pour revisiter les
articles de la déclaration universelle
les 30 articles qui souvent
malheureusement en sont oubliés et
surtout qui sont bafoués au quotidien
sur toute la planète des street artistes
investissent l'entrée d'exposition en
découvrant les escaliers déclarations de
sebastiao salgado est à découvrir
jusqu'au 30 juin au musée de l'homme et
c'est la fin de votre sexe choisir je
vous donne rendez vous la semaine
prochaine pour de nouvelles c'était
sorti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]